[Music]
have you watched it i tried to watch the
pilot and it was
there's something about like watch like
i was telling you about this like
degrassi back in the day the biggest
thing
it's like
you had sex with jj yeah whatever she's
like i don't yeah we're in love and it's
like that's like kind of scandalous
because you're young and it's like
whatever it's very believable of like
that's come on yeah and then there's
like one guy who owns one fender guitar
they bought from like a walmart and he
does cocaine yeah and they're like
you're not gonna make it he's like i
could try right you know that kind of
thing euphoria it was like watching 15
year olds act like they're bukowski yeah
and they're like existence is pain but i
stop it and i move forward because life
is a shell like all this kind of stuff
where i'm like you're 15 years old
you can have some traumatic [ __ ] but
like your life is so new still to where
it's so it's just odd and also what the
[ __ ] is going on with the outfits
i remember i remember like half the time
i was like this is getting all
scandalous yeah looking like people when
leggings came out with ugg boots yeah
i mean you know what i mean jersey shore
era [ __ ] you're like oh my god you can
see her butt quack yeah kind of thing
through her pants i mean my high schools
was
decently crazy you four-ish
yeah well i guess probably carney
missouri might have not had that
influence yeah
yeah girls walk around with leggings and
you didn't really care that they were
wearing like a 2008 toby keith concert
t-shirt and stuff nah my high school was
like it was like
uh it was how
like much could you show it was the damn
trying to push really a girl tried
twerking at a prom and she got like
a bunch of days
like off of
like oss days off
yeah they're like taking a couple days
they don't even expel at your school
they're just like listen take a few days
go to church think about it it was kids
trying to be kids you know yeah but they
like were playing music too like they
played johnny paycheck
at my at my prom i was prom king by the
way you were
they played johnny paycheck which even
on a giant paycheck he's great yeah
there's johnny paycheck
yeah no my high school was definitely
euphorious the craziest [ __ ] is these
kids like
they called it tweek and i think tweek
is meth
but they did math next to me in class
wow yeah yeah it was like a lot of
people saw them pills and uh um a lot of
people sold pills in school wait can you
can you google can you snort meth
so yeah tweak his math look at me i
thought it was the whole thing and was
it pulp fiction doesn't she oh no no she
snorts heroin that's what [ __ ] her up
i've seen kids do drugs
uh snorting oh yeah you can
um dangers of snorting smoking or
injecting meth dude our [ __ ] ip has
probably the most hilarious
yeah the the dude or the fbi that's like
watching your guys's browser history
it's just like damn these kids are going
in
yeah look at a short circuit i was
wondering how to
just send your friend like a facebook
message and just be like there is no
healthy way to ingest meth yeah
i got it i just get a text just like a
random ass number like yo just stop yeah
enough yeah they pulled out like one of
those like mini like coke baggies
one of the kids uh you know
he was you know just nothing in his
eyeballs and he turned to the kid next
to me who i was like acquainted with
um
that kid would just come to class all
the time and say dude so many shrooms
last night i hated that [ __ ] yeah same
with college people dabbed a lot
you know what's cool about
turning on a blow torch to do your drug
not a lot yeah
it kind of kills the mood
people listen to die ant at an art at an
art school and all of a sudden i was
just like you guys trying to dab up
like you all [ __ ] up that is yeah and
especially like there's like freshmen
over there like hey i'm new to the
illustrations
and he's like you like weed dude you
have smoke before yeah i hit this [ __ ]
you guys just like [ __ ] blacked out
like
yeah smoke's like literally like a diet
we're blessing i think you're freaking
out and i like you a lot in the
background and [ __ ]
and the kids high on like literally
three weeks worth of weeds yeah he's in
one hit
just [ __ ] dead
dude absolutely dead
i remember
uh
i the first time i had done wax it was
like
my buddy puts like weed
like some like keef in there and wax on
top i took one hit i didn't really smoke
like that
hit it through a bong and i like
it didn't even take an hour and i was
just grabbing my chest i was like yo can
you die from weed in my heart
i got high from it one time i didn't
even smoke it this is an embarrassing
story that i usually don't like to tell
because it is it's very
it doesn't look good on me he had the
[ __ ] had it out had cut apples
in that wax out on the thing i thought
it was caramel oh no
oh no what did you do i did a little dip
of it and i'm like oh i was like oh
great i was like
[ __ ] but i don't smoke or anything so
i was [ __ ]
i was like dude
i was like what the [ __ ] is this he's
like wait did you just dip that apple in
there i thought it was caramel he's like
why would we have caramel on a piece of
tin foil i'm like i don't know
i gotta get the [ __ ] out of here
jesus christ dude i was bummed too
because they were honey crisp apples and
i really like honey what are you bro
you should have been in euphoria man
yeah but the thing too is they make a
look also there's nothing really sexy
about like a 20 like a
21 year old
overweight kid with a hawaiian shirt on
accident all sweaty i got super sweaty
very hot night dipping apples and wax
yeah that can euphoria has their
cinematography has done a great job of
sexualizing everything they could
sexualize that okay yeah i'd love to see
it they could make that hot
just showing all the beads of sweat
rolling down hitting my
chest hair yeah going down like uh was
that palinko yeah yeah yeah it goes down
and they they subtly put the sounds of
the prices right in the background as
it's hitting your hairs is that the
level
yeah yeah or whatever
and then it'll be zendaya narrating
yeah
what is life no it'll be like hunter was
a [ __ ] yeah you with like eight girls at
a table like who wants to get [ __ ]
high just just a bag of like 12 honey
crisp apples yeah
he was he was sick we called him wild
card
[Laughter]
he was debaucherous but more importantly
hungry
exactly he was always hungry we called
him wild card because we didn't know if
he was gonna get the most [ __ ] up or
if he was just gonna take us to
mcdonald's or get the most [ __ ] or
get the most [ __ ] because he was
hungry for all sorts of things yeah and
then mostly attention he had a really
hard child you know goes yeah then they
go to your childhood exactly so you like
then your mom and your mom's like eat
the [ __ ] lasagna yeah anything's
apples yeah yeah and then you then you
grow up
you get a black eye and you grow up and
then now you're fast forward in the at
the euphoria high school party my first
line in euphoria what's up wild card i
go by tt now yeah
and i never explained why yeah but i
want to be called tt for now on yeah
what's up tt yeah and one kid's like hey
teddy and i'm like don't
no no he says that's it yeah and all the
jocks in the party turned like excuse me
what the [ __ ] did you just say the tt
dude and then you go together that's
your boy you go to get up and like no no
no i got this
you won't last a [ __ ] day in this
town
you won't last a day at euphoria high
don't come to school tomorrow because
we're all gonna [ __ ] you up and then
sleep with your girlfriend
your girlfriend who's here who can hear
this conversation we're going to do it
she's like it's not going to happen
tt
tt said what he said
we're going to beat your to you we're
going to beat you to a bloody [ __ ]
corpse and we're going to do cocaine on
your corpse tt why are your eyes open
i'll [ __ ] kill you dude
you realize that you want to die tonight
so then yeah after after the jocks
threaten the kid for like [ __ ] with
tt
the music comes back on
and and then the then zendaya's voice
comes back in and she's like oh yeah and
titi
love to party and then that's when you
break out the apples and you're dipping
it in the tin foil and everyone's like
titty
it's like but in this version i like it
and i was like i did it intentionally
because i want to get highest exactly
400 uh oh my gosh
[Applause]
400 zombie nation starts playing it's
like
and i go and there's like all strobing
and [ __ ] yeah and then you're just on
the dance floor with the apples yeah and
then the scene gets interrupted because
then they're like has anyone seen cassie
she's literally doing [ __ ] meth right
now
dude shut up i watched the tt dance yeah
exactly like
no one cares yeah and then it cuts to
cassie walking down the street butt ass
naked punching through cars
dude stop
someone has to stop her [ __ ] you nathan
dude what is this oh i think she's like
superhuman strong or something wait yo
isn't that nathan's car she's eating
nathan's car oh
no nathan comes out shirtless how the
[ __ ] am i gonna get home that was my
dad's mercedes [ __ ]
cliffhanger